we're also seeing all across the country
where people are alone and they are
struggling with this
but until you're sitting in that chair
you don't understand how lonely it is to
you
well i'm an only child my parents are
deceased
i was never married and i don't have
children
so it's lonely who's there for you
my friends yeah friends my doctors
yes but uh good friends
loyal friends none of those mothers from
a tv show
jojo and her family have been wonderful
have they yes
how proud are you of joe jones she's
very proud i'm very proud
what do you what do you what do you
think of what jojo has done
i i don't know if she's just a marketing
genius and we don't know this yet
uh i'm proud of her i'm proud of
everything that she does and it's great
energy to be around for me
it's it's uplifting and it's fun and
it's positive
and it's exciting and i like that you
know i've been to their home many many
times
uh you know they're they're there to
talk to they're there to call
you know and uh jojo calls me and texts
me with every exciting
new thing that she has coming up so it's
good to be involved
to be you know not forgotten
oh well we used you we we're famous now
we don't need you anymore
it's more of a continue the journey
together
oh that's beautiful um was jojo how hard
was it for jojo to hide something like
this
but i never had fallen in love before
um but i always believed that like my
person was just gonna be my person
and if that person happened to be a boy
great and if that person happened to be
a girl great
i don't think she hides anything really
i think
maybe she just didn't know i have a lot
of students
that uh struggle with their sexuality i
will be honest mainly
guys that dance for me throughout the
years uh
some have come to me and said you know
without you
i would have committed suicide to hear
that as a teacher
is shocking and and also
very loving and kind that i knew that i
did that for that child
and uh a lot of the guys struggle with
that and i
you know teach them to be very masculine
on stage and when they're performing
and what you do in your private life is
your business but uh
jojo really didn't have a private life
her life is
you know for the whole world to know
about every single thing that she's
doing with social media now everybody
knows what we're doing and what we're up
to every moment
and we tell them we share it so for her
to make that
statement and to share that and that's
what she wanted to do
i'm proud that she had the guts to do it
and she has a great environment and
her family and everybody you know hey
i'm single and sometimes guys are jerks
so
good for her and that's what i said i
said you know what jojo that's more hot
young guys out there for me
it's good
you